j'en viens maintenant à notre second
débat l'actualité c'est aussi la
polémique sur le burkini dans les
piscines de Grenoble le Conseil d'État
était appelé aujourd'hui à trancher la
question Marion Delpech
la décision du Conseil d'État ne
manquera pas de ranimer le débat
politique le recours déposé par la
municipalité de Grenoble concernant
l'autorisation du burkini dans les
piscines municipales de la ville était
examiné aujourd'hui par le Conseil
d'État ce nouveau règlement avait été
voté à une très courte majorité par le
conseil municipal l'opposition portée
par Alain Carignan estimait que cette
modification remettait en cause le
vivre-ensemble et faisait reculer la
cause des femmes nous allons donc décidé
de quitter cette séance ensemble parce
que comme des membres de la majorité
l'ont souligné
Eric Piol n'était pas légitime pour
prendre une telle décision elle est
visiblement minoritaire ici et elle est
minoritaire chez les Grenoblois quelques
jours plus tard le tribunal
administratif de Grenoble ordonnée alors
la suspension de cette mesure les
jugésimés que l'un des articles du
Règlement portaient gravement atteinte
au principe de neutralité du service
public le maire écologiste Eric Piol
avait aussi tôt fait par deux sa volonté
de faire appel de cette suspension
devant le Conseil d'État les deals
justifient sa position au nom de la loi
de 1905 qui assure la liberté de culte
c'est le respect du culte et donc
personne ne peut faire pression sur vous
pour vous forcer à exercer un culte et
personne ne peut vous empêcher de de
d'exercer le culte la décision sera mise
en délibérée dans quelques jours et
notre débat sur la laïcité on commence
déjà à discuter sur ce plateau je vous
présente mes invités radicales nanime en
soi bienvenue vous êtes philosophe
islamologue membre du Conseil
d'orientation de la fondation de l'islam
de France auteur de Islam quel problème
les défis de la réforme publiés aux
éditions Vaska up blisher Gaspard Konig
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes philosophe
fondateur du mouvement simple
j'accueille également Ismail ferrade
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
professeur en sciences de l'éducation à
l'université de Nanterre et je cite
votre livre des discriminations
sous-estimer les musulmans en France
c'est aux Éditions de l'Aube laetitia
cruppa est resté à mes côtés
éditorialistes politiques je vais vous
poser histoire de savoir un peu où vous
positionner les uns les autres la même
question pour commencer est-ce que vous
soutenez ou pas la décision du maire de
Grenoble d'autoriser le burkini dans les
piscines municipales Razika Nani vous
aviez envoyé à Éric Piol une une lettre
ouverte qu'on a retrouvé qui était
publiée dans dans Marianne pour dire
quoi
pour d'abord lui dire ce que je pense de
cette décision et étant donné que pour
moi un élu de la République qui déclare
sur les chaînes de télévision et sur les
zones de radio les zones de radio que le
port du burkini qui est la version
maillot de bain du voile était ainsi une
religieux et une pratique et qui faisait
et qui fait partie de la pratique du
culte pour moi c'est c'est l'élu de la
République qui prend position dans un
débat théologique qui divise aujourd'hui
au sein de l'islam et des musulmans
aujourd'hui les musulmans se divisent en
deux parties ce qui déclare que le voile
est inscrit dans le Coran donc c'est une
prescription coranique obligatoire pour
les femmes et d'autres qui disent que le
voile n'est pas prescrit dans le Coran
donc il n'est pas obligatoire pour les
femmes personnellement je fais partie de
la deuxième position donc qu'un élu de
la République déclare que c'est un c'est
un signe religieux et une pratique du
culte pour moi il y a là un dépassement
par rapport à la laïcité et ça fait
partie pardon aussi de mon travail dans
le domaine de la réforme de l'islam
étant donné que je suis pour
construire un nouvel Islam plus adapté à
cette époque et défendre le voile fait
partie d'un islam traditionnel
fondamentaliste et il est évident que je
réagisse et finalement pour la dernière
dernier point c'est que le voile est une
pratique discriminatoire à l'égard des
femmes et donc il est normal que je
réagisse étant donné que je défends
l'égalité en femme c'est dans Les Echos
que votre tribune sur ce thème a été
publié alors vous vous affirmez que
cette polémique n'a pas lieu d'être
pourquoi vous dites ça d'abord je
reprends les propos de Jacques tout bon
là franchement il se lament gauchiste et
qui était défenseur des droits qui est
un qui est très rigoureux sur la
question de l'État droit des libertés
fondamentales et qui dit tout simplement
on aurait jamais dû en parler la
définition de la laïcité elle est très
claire depuis 1905 les la manifestation
des pratiques religieuses en public et
dans l'espace public et parfaitement
autorisé simplement l'État doit être
neutre par rapport à ces pratiques mais
l'espace public ne doit pas être neutre
à partir du moment où ça ne trouble pas
l'ordre public
donc en ce sens il y a même pas de
questions que ça soit une manifestation
religieuse ou pas en fait on s'en fiche
c'est juste un vêtement la seule
question c'est de savoir s'il y a des
hygiène et de sécurité qui pourrait
empêcher le port d'intellatement dans
une piscine si on a pas il peut y avoir
d'autres questions égalité homme-femme
etc mais d'un point de vue de la laïcité
les choses sont extrêmement claires donc
la décision pardon nous interrompre la
décision d'Eric pioles vous y êtes
plutôt favorable complètement favorable
mais c'est à dire que je vois je vois
pas où est le débat après dire qu'on est
en faveur de cette décision n'est pas
dire qu'on est pour le burkini et ça il
faut quand même bien distinguer deux
choses mais c'est comme la liberté
d'expression dire que vous avez le droit
de dire des âneries n'est pas encourager
ces âneries dire que les gens ont le
droit de porter le burkini parce que
c'est leur choix et que ce qui fait le
sens et la fierté de nos sociétés
ouvertes nos sociétés libres et que les
gens ont le droit de faire leur choix à
partir du moment ils sont majeurs ils
sont responsables et oui ils ne nuisent
pas autrui c'est pas dire que ensuite à
titre ça c'est titre légal disons
ensuite à titre personnel culturel
civique on peut parfaitement expliquer
que ces discriminatoires que c'est pas
bien et mener un combat mais qui n'est
pas un combat on va mener à travers le
droit et donc qu'un élu dise bah oui les
gens ont droit de faire ça me semble
parfaitement correct il faut surtout pas
mélanger dans ces questions là le droit
et la morale et c'était exactement ce
que répondait Aristide Briand en 1905 à
ceux qui avaient une version qu'on
appelait à l'époque intégrale de la
laïcité qui disait par exemple il faut
interdire auprès d'avoir une soutane
dans la rue exactement le même sujet et
le sujet avait été tranché en disant
l'ency claricalisme c'est une chose car
ici brillant à quelle heure était plutôt
favorable mais la laïcité s'en est une
autre et donc on a le droit de porter
des signes religieux dans la rue
aujourd'hui en France et bien sûr sur la
neutralité est absurde puisque si le
service public est neutre c'est les
agents qu'on obligation de neutralité
mais absolument pas les usagers après il
y a un autre débat mais on va en parler
on a on a du temps qui est sur le le
l'islam politique ou le rôle social de
l'islam et ceux qui disent attention
quand on sait de sur un thème comme le
on va essayer sur le planises on y
viendra Loire République bien entendu
mais on y viendra un peu plus tard dans
le débat si vous le si vous le voulez
bien il se met le ferrade qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de la décision du maire de
Grenoble alors ce qu'il faut souligner
c'est que le débat c'est déjà posé il y
a quelques années en 2016 lorsqu'il y a
eu plusieurs donc communes qui avaient
interdit le burkini sur les plages le
Conseil d'État avait répondu la vie
c'est tout à fait légale donc je rejoins
ce que dit tout à fait c'est que on est
dans un pays où la laïcité s'applique
aux agents du service public en moi je
peux pas venir en cours avec une grande
croix ou entre signe religieux par
contre dans l'espace public que ce soit
effectivement la plage la rue alors on
verra pour la piscine puisqu'il y a un
recours administratif qui est encore en
cours au Conseil des fin qui va être au
Conseil d'État météoriquement ce qui a
été tranché en 2016 et qui a été
confirmé donc à ce moment-là c'est que
le burkini n'est pas en tant que tel
interdit à des personnes qui souhaitent
le porter et je rejoins ce qui a été dit
on peut très bien être critique du
burkini hein sur le fond en disant d'un
point de vue culturel idéologique
philosophique c'est à cause de vouloir
couvrir le corps de la femme parce qu'il
serait impudique parce que c'est bien ça
qui a derrière mais une fois qu'on a dit
ça le droit de porter telle ou tel
vêtement est un droit qui est permis la
laïcité rappelle que article 1 et 2 la
loi 1905
les libertés de conscience sont
respectées à une seule condition c'est
que l'ordre public ne soit pas troubler
est-ce que le burkini suffit à trouver
l'ordre public le Conseil d'État
tranchera Laetitia moi je trouve ça bien
hypocrite vos positions messieurs je
vous le dis vraiment voilà d'un point de
façon un peu un peu immédiate comme cela
parce que
se retrancher derrière le paravent de la
loi certes mais enfin la loi est faite
par les hommes et donc pas nature évolue
voilà donc et c'est revenir sur la loi
de 1905 c'est absolument
dans la rue alors la soutane justement
c'est cet exemple est vraiment illustre
tout à fait là vos positions c'est un
choix quand on est prêtre c'est vraiment
une vocation c'est un sacerdoce donc
c'est le choix du prêtre allez
questionner le choix de la femme qui
portera à burkini elle ne vous dira
jamais monsieur directement que ce n'est
pas son choix mais celui peut-être de
son père de son frère de son époux et
c'est toute la problématique de masquer
et de voiler le corps de la femme
d'accord mais il y a toute une dimension
symbolique que vous balayez d'un revers
de main parce qu'il y a la loi française
et bien non je crois que la loi évolue
je crois qu'il on ne peut pas quand il
s'agit encore une fois de la moitié de
l'humanité parce qu'on est là aussi à
côté de vous depuis le début voilà
balayer d'un revers de main tout de la
question
très problématique du choix qui ce qui
est absolument individuel mais qu'on ne
pourra jamais vraiment définir et donc
vous pouvez brimer la liberté d'une
femme je sais pas vous avez pas écouté
ce que j'ai dit j'ai dit qu'on
distinguait deux plans le plan de la loi
qui permet l'expression de du culte ou
l'expression d'ailleurs de ce qu'on veut
dans l'espace public tant que ça ne nuit
pas autrui et sur ce plan-là je pense
qu'il est tout à fait déraisonnable
d'interdire le port d'un vêtement dans
l'espace public que ça sera probablement
cassé pour le Conseil d'État pas
seulement parce que c'est la loi mais
parce que la loi est bien fondée et que
cette loi de 1905 a précisément permis
un processus de sécularisation par
rapport à l'église catholique parce
qu'on a laissé les gens vivre et que peu
à peu les consciences ont évolué donc
oui c'est la loi cette loi est bien
faite est-ce que vous dites remet en
cause les fondements même du pacte
républicain je dis juste que sur la
question religieuse après il y a un
deuxième plan sur lequel je vous rejoins
mais il ne faut surtout pas les
confondre qui le plan moral culturel
individuel de savoir comme vous le
disiez ce que représente ce vêtement si
c'est un et là bien sûr que à titre
personnel d'abord je n'en sais trop rien
parce que je ne rentre pas dans
l'intimité des consciences que je n'ai
pas assez d'informations sur le sujet
que je vois de femmes d'ailleurs qui dit
c'est mon choix d'autres c'est pas mon
choix etc mais c'est un autre débat
c'est un débat de la société civile ce
n'est pas bien entendu ce débat juste
pour finir ce débat pourra avoir lieu de
manière saine ordonnée avec des points
de vue contradictoires si on ne fait pas
intervenir l'État pour imposer un choix
pour préempter une décision alors
justement le Razika Nani peut-être qu'il
faut faire un peu d'histoire religieuse
quoi pourquoi se voile est imposé aux
femmes par la religion musulmane se
répand juste un petit peu
le voile a une histoire il a une culture
et là et une culture sociale une culture
théologique contour il a des objectifs
on ne peut pas il a un discours on ne
peut pas faire fille de tout cela et
l'aborder juste comme un vêtement que la
loi permet de porter dans ce cas de
symbole associé
qui sont derrière et la femme qui le
porte c'est la femme musulmane elle le
porte dans cette culture-là donc elle le
porte entourée par cette culture et à ce
moment-là si on fait pas attention à ces
éléments que l'on et qui l'entoure on
risque d'arriver à une situation où
l'égalité la laïcité la liberté se
retourne contre la femme et contre la
République française elle-même quand
pour l'interdiction du voile tout court
à ce moment-là je dis qu'il faut la rue
partout qu'on comprenne son discours ce
qui moi je travaille sur le dans le
domaine de la réforme de l'islam
j'explique premièrement que le voile
n'est pas une prescription coranique
déjà et qu'on n'a pas le droit
aujourd'hui de de manière je pense qu'on
se trompe de la border sur le plan
religieux il faut l'aborder sur le plan
de discrimination car c'est pour cet
objectif là qu'il a été instauré il a
été instauré avant l'Islam donc
savoir si la loi doit être ouverts
que la loi permet de s'habiller comme on
veut je pense que la loi sur la laïcité
ne parle pas de du vêtement
elle parle de manifestations de toutes
les les
convictions religieuses je voudrais
juste poser une question la polycamie
existe encore
le châtiment de la main coupée existe
l'esclavage existe
qu'est-ce que vous allez dire si un jour
on vous dit ça fait partie de
l'expression de notre religion on a le
droit public
si le voile trouble l'ordre public ça
veut dire qu'il faut réguler l'ensemble
du champ parce que il faut l'égalité
premièrement si vous dites ça si vous
êtes pour l'interdiction du voile
partout l'égalité homme
c'est à la loi française de prendre une
décision moi je suis pas juriste je suis
en train de dire en France que le voile
il n'est pas inscrit dans le Coran je
parle de la de la dissimulation de la
chevelure de la femme il n'y a aucun
verset qui dit que la femme doit
dissimulé sa chevelure il est entouré
par tout un discours il est
discriminatoire et c'est au juriste de
prendre leur décision
intervenir dans dans cette partie du
débat ce qui est intéressant aussi on va
y venir tout à l'heure on va parler
beaucoup d'écoles dans ce dans ce débat
c'est finalement on parle de laïcité et
on ne parle quasiment que l'islam est-ce
que c'est comme ça que le ressentent
aussi les vous êtes référent laïcité
dans je crois que c'est dans laquelle
Universal aujourd'hui
est-ce que c'est comme ça que c'est reçu
par les élèves finalement alors je
voulais juste répondre
effectivement nous sommes deux hommes
donc je tiens à souligner
qu'effectivement c'est une problématique
qui peut tous toucher les femmes ça
c'est important de le dire dans ce
cas-là il serait peut-être bien l'invité
des femmes qui portent le burkini pour
être totalement justes et c'est pas
souvent le cas me semble-t-il donc
petite remarque méthodologique si on
veut parler avec les personnes
concernées il faut parler jusqu'au bout
avec les personnes concernées donc les
personnes qui qui portent émotion
burkini je pense qu'il serait
intéressant parce qu'effectivement
peut-être qu'ils auraient un point de
vue que je partage pas par ailleurs
forcément mais qui aurait un point de
vue intéressant parce que la
mobilisation à Grenoble et portée par
des femmes et manifestement il y a pas
beaucoup d'hommes donc effectivement ça
pose aussi une question de certaines
femmes qui ont des positions
certainement puritaines conservatrices
de ce point de vue là alors
effectivement les depuis maintenant une
trentaine d'années en gros depuis
l'affaire du foulard de 89 lorsqu'on
parle laïcité très souvent en
arrière-plan on pense à l'islam c'est
pas la peine au niveau du pot on sait
que c'est le cas depuis quelques
décennies et les débats depuis quelques
années un tourne très largement sur
l'islam pensant au burkini pensant maman
accompagnatrice à l'école pensant à la
question des signes religieux à l'école
très souvent c'est la question de
l'islam qui est mise en avant et il y a
un effet qui est très net lorsqu'on
interroge par exemple les lycéens sur le
ressenti vis-à-vis de la laïcité un
sondage a été mené par l'ifope pour la
lycra il y a un an qui était publié il y
a un an et on va les lycéens de quartier
populaire de lycée professionnel et de
culture musulmane répondre que la
laïcité vise une religion l'Islam donc
effectivement ça a des effets petit à
petit sur une partie de la jeunesse qui
identifie la laïcité non pas quand même
principe libéral ce qu'il est à
l'origine où je confirme absolument le
fait que c'est une loi libérale au sens
propre du terme puisqu'elle dit que
l'État n'intervient pas mais c'est
intéressant parce que les uns et les
autres vous brandissez la liberté en
fait pour pour justifier vos arguments
la liberté des femmes la liberté dans
l'équilibre notre République s'intéresse
mais en fait c'est même pas brandir la
liberté c'est rappeler la loi tout
simplement enfin moi je suis encore une
fois j'ai dit service public j'ai des
étudiants de voilée à Nanterre il y en a
quelques-unes moi je me vois mal leur
dire rentrer chez vous enfin venez pas
en cours enfin je trouve que d'un point
de vue pédagogique ce serait destructeur
je peux avoir une opinion sur le foulard
mais si demain la loi évolue elle peut
évoluer et c'est très souvent dit ça
peut avoir des conséquences délétères
pour ces étudiantes mais ça rejoint ce
que j'évoquais rapidement tout à l'heure
on peut y venir sur le le les enjeux
politiques ou le ou le rôle politique de
l'islam est-ce que vous imaginez ou vous
pouvez concevoir que ce soit un acte
militant le fait de porter le burkini le
voile interdire plus ça va devenir un
acte militant ça c'est sûr bref permet
le voile dans ces piscines municipales
depuis 2014 comme on en a pas parlé ça
ne pose pas de problème il y a quelques
femmes qui le sont mais elles sont une
poignée et j'aimerais revenir sur la
distinction que fait Jean bobéro qui est
pour moi un grand historien de la
laïcité en tout cas c'est ma référence
quand je parle de ce sujet et il dit il
faut bien distinguer la comme cadre
légal donc ça c'est ce qu'on a rappelé
je pense que sur le fond légal c'est
relativement indiscutable on a bien
compris il faudrait changer la loi et
puis on veut interdire sur la conception
française
et le processus de sécularisation moi je
suis athée à titre personnel je suis
plutôt
disons nicher sur le thème du est mort
qu'est-ce que tout ça pourquoi est-ce
qu'on suit n'importe quel prescriptions
religieuses que ça que que ce soit c'est
des transcendants qui n'ont plus lieu
d'être qui sont obsolètes soyons
immenses soit une société libre c'est
plutôt c'est plutôt ça mon origine mon
point de vue mais je pense que si on
essaye d'imposer ça aux gens en disant
non regardez maintenant il faut être il
faut être anti religieux c'est ça la
modernité on va créer exactement l'effet
inverse
comment est-ce que je reviens sur ce
terme de sécularisation d'emplois bobéro
comment est-ce que la société française
c'est sécularisée c'est précisément
parce qu'on a dit bon bah on trie des
problèmes vous avez parfaitement le
droit de faire vos pratiques de faire
tout ça on a nous le droit de les
critiquer et puis on va prendre le temps
de voir qui gagne entre guillemets et ça
a pris un siècle un siècle et demi et
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui la société
française est largement sécularisée et
que la religion catholique c'est
complètement fondu dans l'espace public
et que globalement effectivement ça pose
plus tellement de il y a encore quelques
cas ici ou là mais ça pose plus
tellement de problèmes je pense que si
on veut que ce processus de
sécularisation se fasse pour l'Islam et
bien il faut lui laisser une marge de
liberté de manœuvre et quelque part
d'auto-analyse moi j'avais été reçu à la
mosquée à Nour rapidement puisse prendre
la parole qui a fait beaucoup de bruit
parce que c'était une mosquée qui a fait
la une de mes valeurs actuelles qui
étaient censé avec moi
et eux ils avaient un discours disant
mais nous la laïcité c'est le cadre dans
lequel on peut évoluer parce que
précisément la laïcité à la française
contrairement à d'autres pays où telle
religion ou prise sur une autre ou tel
état essaie de contrôler quelque chose
c'est quelque chose qui nous laisse
vivre et qui nous laisse évoluer et donc
si on veut que la religion évolue et je
pense dans le bon sens et dans le sens
de se diluer peu à peu dans l'espace
séculaire et bien il faut mettre ses
garde-fous qui sont prévus par loi de
1905 et qui ont marché qui ont marché
concernant la religion catholique qui
permettent aux gens de faire leur chemin
alors selon leur chemin de conscience
ça fait plus sens j'enlève vous dites
grosso modo laissant le temps à la
religion islamique de s'adapter c'est
votre thème la réforme de l'islam je
pense que vous parlez
vous tenez un discours de quelqu'un qui
ignore complètement la religion
musulmane et son histoire et donc je
comprends ce que vous dites mais je ne
vois pas du tout que les se passe comme
vous le dites
premièrement les musulmans il faut
savoir que dans leur histoire dès le
8ème siècle ils ont posé la question de
la définition de l'islam ils ont ils se
sont interrogés si l'islam était
uniquement et spiritualité ou une
spiritualité et une organisation sociale
ils ont fini par trancher en faveur de
ce que moi j'appelle l'islam des
juristes autrement dit l'islam qui dit
il n'est il est impossible de dissocier
la dimension spirituelle de la dimension
juridique française jusqu'à la
Révolution française
la question de la laïcité a été posée
parce que les musulmans se sont ouverts
sur la culture française et la culture
occidentale ils ont compris qu'on
pouvait séparer la religion de la
politique et ils se sont posés cette
question les islamistes ont réagi ils
ont mis en place un principe qui dit que
l'islam est une religion et un état et
ce principe a
comment dirais-je à influencer la pensée
et la conscience des musulmans depuis
car les Frères musulmans n'ont pas cessé
de le répéter donc dire que il va
l'islam va évoluer comme ça
naturellement tout seul parce qu'on lui
permet de s'exprimer et bien je pense
que vous vous trompez totalement l'islam
est vous le et doit évoluer parce que je
travaille dans le domaine de la réforme
comme vous il faut leur expliquer
pourquoi il doit évoluer donc quand on
leur dit non le port du voile est une
liberté je réagis pour dire non ce n'est
pas une liberté il faut une réforme de
l'islam il faut leur expliquer où se
situe le problème pour qu'ils puissent
aller vers cette nouvelle grâce à vous
il va évoluer grâce à ce genre d'action
on a entendu vos arguments
on va en attendant
on va parler plus précisément maintenant
de la question de la laïcité à l'école
je vous propose pour commencer une
déclaration signée Emmanuel Macron
c'était le 2 juin dernier il est à
Marseille il réagit un article de nos
confrères de l'opinion sur
l'augmentation des tenues islamiques
dans les collèges et les lycées
il doit y avoir aucun tabou aucun
interdit et non plus aucun fantasme et
donc moi je veux la vérité la clarté sur
tous les chiffres et ensuite je veux que
la loi de la République s'applique et la
loi est très claire pour tous les pour
tous les élèves dans nos écoles il n'y a
pas de signes religieux auxquels qu'ils
soient pourquoi parce que nous formons
des citoyens en devenir donc je vais
très clair sur ce sujet nous allons avec
Monsieur le Ministre regardez mesurer et
répondre avec la plus grande clarté à
toutes les situations qui ne respectent
pas la loi de la République voilà et sur
ce thème j'appelle Jérémy Hitman à nous
rejoindre tout de suite sur le plateau
de sciences publiques rebonsoir Jérémy
avec donc cette cette information on
constaterait une hausse des incidents
liés aux ports de signes religieux dans
les établissements scolaires et oui
selon une note du service central du
renseignement territorial l'héritier des
renseignements généraux qui datent de la
semaine dernière et bien 144 entorse à
la loi de 2004 ont été recensés par le
ministère de l'Éducation nationale entre
janvier et mars 2021 ce qui représente
en fait une hausse de près de 50% par
rapport au premier trimestre des
incidents qui augmentent principalement
dans le secondaire et dans certains
territoires le gars Bordeaux ou encore
le Val-d'Oise le type d'incident n'est
pas précisé mais les situations décrites
dans la note font référence en majorité
au port du voile ou de tenue
traditionnelles par les élèves
informations révélées par nos confrères
de RTL ce matin on parle d'entorse à la
loi de 2004 que dit cette loi et bien
elle est votée le 15 mars 2004 sous
Jacques Chirac le texte interdit le port
de cygne ou tenu par lesquels les élèves
manifestent
ostentibles ostensiblement pardon une
appartenance religieuse dans les écoles
collèges et lycée public une circulaire
précise que les signes visés sont le
voile islamique la kippa ou une croix de
taille manifestement excessive autre
texte important ce livre voté le 11
octobre 2010 qui interdit le voile
intégral dans l'espace public et les
élèves sont évidemment les premiers
concernés qu'est-ce qu'ils en pensent et
bien selon un sondage Ifop à un publié
le dernier plus de 50% des lycéens se
disent favorables au port d'un signe
religieux ostensible dans les lycées
publics c'est le cas notamment d'une
grande partie des élèves du lycée
Camille Pissaro à Pontoise que Marion
Delpech a interrogé écoutez
parce que si juste on peut laisser
porter la croix peut-être la kippa ou le
voile peut-être pas intégrale je sais
pas ce que ça signifie ou quoi mais le
voile juste pour la tête ou pas ça me
dérangerait pas porter le voile au lycée
en fait quand c'est mes amis j'ai rien
mais en fait je parle du principe que si
tout le monde commence à faire ça va ça
part un peu dans tous les sens selon moi
ça devrait être toléré pas de raison que
ça soit pas en fait enfin tant que ça
tant que ça dérange pas d'autres
personnes ce que je veux dire les gens
serait intéressant on va dire vis-à-vis
de la religion ils ont de plus envie de
pratiquer leur religion et de le montrer
mais bon je pense que les limites fixées
par l'école reste toujours présente en
fait
alors des limites toujours présentes
mais des jeunes on l'a entendu qui
proposent donc une vision plus inclusive
de la laïcité assez proche finalement
d'une laïcité à l'anglosaxonne merci
Jérémy pour pour ces détails Ismaël
Ferhat je rappelle que c'est vraiment le
domaine sur lequel vous vous intervenez
la laïcité est-ce que une question
double est-ce que un vous voyez
apparaître ces signes extérieurs de
religion et vous les voyez augmenter
depuis quelques mois et deux comment
réagissent que peuvent faire les
directeurs d'établissement en fait face
à ça alors ce qu'il faut le souligner
c'est que les chiffres d'atteinte à la
laïcité c'est un débat assez ancien il
faut savoir que les renseignements
généraux donc ancêtres du renseignement
territorial avait commencé à
s'intéresser au foulard en 90 donc après
l'affaire du foulard de 89 et à l'époque
il comptait 400 foulards dans les
collèges les chiffres n'ont jamais
beaucoup évolué c'est toujours quelques
centaines quelques dizaines donc c'est
pas énorme un rappelant qu'on dit 144k
il y a 12 millions d'élèves
donc il y a pas un statisticien en
France il dirait que c'est significatif
très clairement d'ailleurs je suis
étonné qu'on parle de 50% enfin en
première fête en fait il y avait 90 cas
au premier trimestre il y en a 144
en sciences sociales donc ce qui me
ferait beaucoup c'est que le sujet est
apparent en fait depuis quelques années
en réalité à ses pas neuf ce qu'il faut
souligner c'est que la note est
intéressante sur un autre point c'est
comment on définit un signe religieux la
loi 2004 et surtout la circulaire de
l'application du 18 mai en fait c'est
elle qui précise la loi de 2004 dit en
gros on interdit le foulard c'est la loi
était faite pour ça largement la kippal
grande croix et le turban cycle qui
était au fait le quatrième signe qui
pouvait poser problème est-ce que une
robe longue et renforcement religieuse
on sait très bien que les élèves qui
portent des robes longues il peut avoir
une inspiration de type salafiste
puritaine ou extrêmement conservatrice
mais est-ce que ça suffit à qualifier le
vêtement de religieux c'est très
complexe donc jusqu'à où on va définir
les vêtements religieux et ça pose la
question des chefs d'établissement à
quel point ils effectivement le vêtement
est religieux et pour le coup la loi
2004 est très claire il y a des signes
qui sont définis on ne peut pas
interpréter tous les vêtements comme
étant des vêtements forcément religieux
je tiens à souligner que par ailleurs
cette tendance à vouloir comment
dirais-je contre les vêtements il va
aussi dans l'autre sens lorsqu'on a eu
le débat sur les nombril à l'air il y a
quelques années on a parlé de Tonio
républicaines donc je l'attends de voir
ce qui est une tenue républicaine
d'un produit de la loi qu'est-ce que
c'est
c'est quelqu'un une réponse moi je
travaille dessus depuis une dizaine
d'années j'ai pas trouvé un texte qui
parle de tenue républicaine à l'école
donc si quelqu'un trouve le texte je
serai intéressé donc vous dites que
aujourd'hui face à ce que les les voilà
je prends plein de de guillemets et de
et de précaution ce que effectivement
les renseignements de territoriaux
qualifient de recrudescence vous dites
que les proviseurs le directeur
d'établissement finalement ils ont pas
grand chose ils ont pas de d'outils
juridique quoi c'est ça ce que je
comprends très clairement la loi 2004
dit si on a un signe religieux sensible
donc qui est défini comme étant
ustensible on discute avec les lèvres ce
qui les lèvres refusent de le retirer
exclusion des écoles publiques parce que
la loi s'applique au public hein le
privé n'est pas concerné
le résultat c'est qu'on fait c'est très
clair donc si on considère dans une
procédure de vie scolaire dans le
conseil de discipline réunion avec les
les lèvres réunions de la communauté
éducative la question est réglée l'élève
est sanctionné donc encore une fois la
loi elle est claire la question est
quelle est la frontière que l'on met en
termes de vêtements est-ce qu'on
considère qu'un vêtement est forcément
religieux parce donc en gros il n'est
pas dans la norme qu'on accepte et
quelle norme on accepte par ailleurs
c'est une question qui à mon avis serait
une boîte de Pandore si on l'ouvre ça
rejoint la question je l'ai posé à
gasparknique mais je peux vous la poser
aussi j'imagine que votre réponse sera
pas tout à fait la même est-ce que c'est
un acte militant finalement de porter le
voile de porter une abaya de porter
voilà une tenue longue etc etc comment
vous payez je pense que c'est juste la
famille qui veut qu'elle porte le voile
pour d'autres elles sont dans un
activisme militant étant donné que les
Frères musulmans dès 1930 ont créé la
branche féminine elle est sur musulmane
et les Frères musulmans dès le départ et
on considéré que la reislamisation des
sociétés musulmanes doit passer par le
voile car le voile et le signe le plus
voyant qui va donner l'aspect d'une
société musulmane donc il faut que les
femmes se voilent pour qu'on sache que
c'est une société musulmane et là ils
ont
beaucoup de femmes ont rejoint donc les
Frères musulmans et elles ont milité
pour que les femmes remettent le voile
dans le monde musulman et en Occident
donc oui il y a des femmes et qui sont
militantes maintenant moi ce que la
question que je me pose
ces élèves là qui mettent ces signes au
son tatouage à l'école normalement
l'école doit leur expliquer ce que
signifie la laïcité et pourquoi ils ont
ils doivent venir à l'école en laissant
leurs signes religieux à la maison ou en
dehors de l'école si le rôle de l'école
de leur expliquer ce que signifie la
laïcité son histoire son objectif son
intérêt et ne pas leur dire que la
laïcité c'est contre la religion mais la
laïcité au contraire elle n'est pas le
refus de la religion mais juste le refus
que la religion interviennent dans la
politique et la gestion de la politique
mais personnellement je terminais juste
avec cette phrase j'ajoute toujours que
la laïcité au contraire elle permet à la
religion de retrouver ça nature première
qui essaie de s'occuper juste de la
relation entre le croyant et la divinité
il se met le faire est-ce que il y a
quand même certains on va pas on va
essayer de d'être le plus lucide
certains collèges ou certains lycées ou
ça devient très difficile de parler de
laïcité sereinement alors ce qu'il faut
souligner c'est qu'il y a eu des
enquêtes pour savoir combien d'élèves
ont étudié la laïcité donc il y a une
enquête qui a été menée en 2020 par un
organisme officiel que le cnesco qui est
un une chaire de recherche donc sur
l'éducation et il avait mesuré que 90%
des collégiens les 80% des lycéens
avaient étudié laïcité donc c'est fait
le travail est fait où effectivement
donc de ce point de vue là la pédagogie
d'aller citer elle a beaucoup progressé
depuis une dizaine d'années ce qui
convient de souligner c'est qu'il est
très compliqué et ça c'est depuis des
années de séparer les problèmes de
laïcité des problèmes de violence
scolaires en réalité l'établissement ou
les problèmes de laïcité sont très
souvent des établissements et des
problèmes de
en gros de violences scolaires de
comportement de provocation et donc la
frontière entre un élève qui va
provoquer contester un cours contester
un enseignement une pratique éducative
parce qu'il aime provoquer ça ne
donnerçant qui cherche les problèmes et
un élève qui cherche des problèmes pour
des raisons religieuses elle est pas
simple rappelons la face la collégienne
qui a été à l'origine du drame est une
collégienne problématique qui avait été
exclu de l'établissement donc on a un
mélange entre religieux et problème de
vie scolaire en réalité donc on a là
typiquement une situation où il y a un
mélange explosif entre d'une part des
comportements problématiques de la part
d'un élève et de son père qui a rajouté
de lui sur le feu et effectivement un
point de vue religieux qui est de dire
pas touche aux religieux lorsqu'on parle
de caricatures de de dessin etc alors
comment le tout nouveau ministre de
l'éducation nationale a réagi face à la
révélation de cette note des des
renseignements territoriaux on écoute
tout de suite pas pendiaye c'était ce
matin juste après le conseil des
ministres il existe évidemment
des lois les lois républicaines sur
l'interdiction de port de signes
religieux
ostensibles et à caractère prosélyte
dans les établissements scolaires donc
nous avons évidemment la loi qui est
très claire à ce sujet il y a aussi des
équipes valeurs de la République dans
chaque rectorat qui travaille sur ces
questions donc nous sommes très bien
équipés pour répondre à ce phénomène
encore faut-il bien le mesurer et bien
l'évaluer à l'échelle nationale je vais
échanger à ce sujet avec les recteurs
dans deux jours pour avoir une vision
aussi claire calme que possible
Laetitia c'est quoi le mot le plus
important selon vous dans cette prise de
parole c'est l'un des derniers c'est le
mot calme il l'a répété à plusieurs
reprises dans cette réponse sur les
signes religieux à l'école il a dit
qu'il fallait regarder calmement la
situation et l'objectif c'est bien sûr
de pacifier absolument ces premiers
messages bien sûr à la communauté
enseignante mais aussi à l'ensemble des
Français pourquoi parce que son arrivée
rue de Grenelle a été accompagnée d'un
tollé à la droite de la droite soyons
clairs Marine Le Pen par exemple a
qualifié de défenseur de l'indigedisme
et du racialisme canter exemmour lui
disait que c'était un vrai intellectuel
indigéniste et un vrai wok plus
généralement à droite c'est vrai que les
mots ont été plus mesurés mais les
critiques ont été tout aussi nombreuses
Thomas qui ont mis en doute finalement
la capacité de papendaï à défendre la
laïcité
caricatures qui qui allaient jusqu'à
dire c'est l'anti blancaire qu'est-ce
qu'on peut est-ce que c'est un peu trop
tôt pour pour répondre c'est c'est
beaucoup trop tôt mais c'est vrai que
Jean-Michel Blanquer en quittant son
ministère à répéter aussi ce mot là et
cité comme un message qui l'envoyait à
son successeur on verra bien ce que
frappe à pendiaye dans ces dans ces
premiers premiers actes en tant que
ministre pour le moment on a quoi en a
ses écrits les écrits de papel DIY oui
c'est vrai que il a étudié une partie il
a fait une partie de aux États-Unis et
il a dit qu'il avait découvert le Mont
Noir en 2008 il a publié la condition
noire donc il a travaillé sur cette
question et cette question anime bien
sûr oui toutes ces réflexions et ces
essais et ces engagements dans l'action
publique aussi il a confondé le cercle
d'action pour la promotion de la
diversité en France et puis le CRAN le
Conseil représentatif des associations
noires de France mais il a opté pour une
approche modérée il se dit par exemple
cool et non pas wok alors après ce sera
lui définir et il rejette tout le
sectarisme de certains
les outrances ce qu'on lui a finalement
reproché le plus c'est son approche du
racisme et alors je vais vous demander
et peut-être au téléspectateurs de
relire c'était dans le monde une
interview en 2017 je vais juste extraire
la phrase qui a pu poser problème il a
dit il n'existe pas de racisme d'État
mais il y a du racisme dans l'État et
des institutions comme la police peuvent
avoir des pratiques racistes c'est ça le
style de papendi la lucidité modérée
mais rien ne dit encore une fois Thomas
qui ne va défendre ses idées là en tant
que ministre de l'éducation nationale
son seul déplacement connus après coup
puisqu'il n'y avait pas de caméra c'est
à Conflans-Sainte-Honorine justement
dans le collège ou enseigner Samuel Paty
Gaspard Konig se débat ont réussi à
avoir il nous reste quelques minutes un
débat pacifié passionnant sur sur ce
thème dès que les politiques s'en
emparent est-ce qu'il est totalement
vici finalement
comme le dit d'ailleurs très bien bobéro
il y a aujourd'hui une laïcité de combat
qui ne correspond pas du tout au texte
et aux valeurs de 1905 qui confond la
laïcité et l'anticléricalisme et
l'antiquitéricalisme dirigé évidemment
contre l'islam et donc on dit il faut
faire de la pédagogie aux enfants dans
les lycées dans les collèges pour leur
apprendre la laïcité encore faudrait-il
que nous adultes soyons capables de
retrouver sa définition originelle et de
nous mettre d'accord sans en faire une
espèce de thème polémique parce qu'on
voit très bien ce qui se passe la droite
et l'extrême droite récupère la laïcité
et l'égalité homme-femme qui sont de
belles valeurs pour en faire en fait des
chevaux de 3 de combat contre l'islam
qui les dérange la France a toujours eu
beaucoup de mal à accueillir d'autres
religions pas brillé avec les huguenots
et on a du mal avec qu'on ait un pays
très jacobin on a du mal à accepter les
cultures différentes une diversité de
valeurs et donc on utilise ces concepts
n'importe comment
pour les combattre au fond et donc il y
a cette hypocrisie très profonde dans
l'utilisation du terme laïcité par la
droite et par l'extrême droite et il est
bon que des gens comme mon voisin qui
sont de déminant juriste face simplement
des rappels sur ce qu'on a décidé
ensemble en 1905 et qui a bien marché
ensuite
[Musique]
enfin je sais pas si on attend de
reparler d'école mais en amour allez-y
en amoureuse 2 minutes en un mot moi je
trouve que précisément parce que il faut
laisser la liberté aux adultes de faire
leur choix il faut être à l'inverse
extrêmement ferme avec les enfants parce
que l'école est un lieu de protection
pour les exposer justement à la
diversité des doctrines et des points de
vue et donc je trouve non seulement
légitime que les enfants soient
que les signes religieux soient
totalement interdits à l'école je pense
qu'on pourrait aller plus loin moi j'ai
vécu quelques années en Angleterre les
enfants mettaient l'uniforme c'est
l'uniforme très léger c'est des petits
t-shirts un pantalon de couleur personne
ne se pose de questions tout le monde
est très égal on regarde pas quelle
marque quel truc quel conviction et tout
ça je pense que c'est une question qu'on
se repose régulièrement et que c'est
plutôt une question de c'est plutôt ça
serait plutôt une avancée qu'un retour
en arrière Razika de Nani qu'est-ce que
vous attendez d'un ministre de
l'éducation nationale comme Pape Ndiaye
sur ce thème de la fermeté oui de la
fermeté non seulement de la part du
ministre mais de la part de l'État
lui-même il faut qu'il ait l'État soit
au sujet de la laïcité évidemment et
il faut savoir que du côté des
fondamentalistes islamistes aussi il y a
toute une lutte contre la laïcité qui se
fait régulièrement et quotidiennement
donc eux ils interviennent à travers les
réseaux sociaux YouTube et donc il
rappelle quotidiennement aux musulmans
de France que la laïcité c'est
l'athéisme de l'État c'est un c'est un
combat contre l'islam et ce discours
aussi n'est pas à ce que les musulmans
se sentent bien dans la laïcité en
France donc il faut aussi
que l'État soit ferme sur ce sujet et
que toujours je reviens au fait qu'il
faut expliquer parfaitement bien ce que
la laïcité signifie celle que vous
défendez celle qui permet voilà à vivre
ensemble avec le respect de l'autre et
la paix merci beaucoup merci à tous
passionnant rasika Anani je rappelle le
titre de votre livre Islam quel problème
les défis de la réforme on est aux
éditions vasca pêcheurs Ismaël Ferhat
les discriminations sous-estimé les
musulmans de France aux éditions de
l'Aube je vous donne rendez-vous demain
et votre prochain rendez-vous politique
sur l'antenne de Public Sénat